les et de la madeleine véritable carte
postale au coeur du golfe du saint
laurent
les madelinots sont fiers de leur
archipel est veuille attirer du monde
l'été oui mais aussi de façon permanente
ils font face à tout un défi
démographique près du quart de la
population ici à 65 ans et plus des
chiffres comparables à ceux de la
gaspésie ou des régions de l'atlantique
beaucoup plus élevé que la moyenne
nationale de 16% les nalbert de
l'entreprise de distribution et de
transformation de crabe et de hobart la
renaissance des il peine à trouver des
employés ce fait deux ans qu'on a un
qu'on accueille des mexicains n'ont
passé on a eu vingt neuf mexicain et
cette année on au 34 la moyenne d'âge
des travailleurs de ses usines et de
cinquante six ans donc c'est très
difficile de recruter des jeunes pour
venir et les gens veulent à arrêtent de
travailler parce qu'il se retire et non
parce qu'ils aiment plus notre travail
des régions rurales et éloignées comme
les îles de la madeleine ne sont pas les
seuls avec ce problème
à plus de 10000 km au japon les régions
se vide plus du quart des japonais en 65
ans et plus annan aucune communauté à
deux heures au nord de tokyo ces 61 % de
la population qui est âgé de plus de 65
ans un record pour le pays avec la
population la plus vieille au monde
en soixante dix ans le nombre d'élèves
de cette école a chuté passant de plus
de 1200 à 25
les classes de 2de 4 et 2 s'élève au
maximum avec cette baisse dramatique
nous pouvons personnaliser notre
enseignement à chaque jeu dit elle
le petit h il ne s'en plaint pas
retourner chez
les gens vanneuse nan beaucoup ne s'est
jamais relevé de l'industrialisation de
l'agriculture
d'autres régions géographiquement plus
avantagés long surpasser sur le plan
économique en quête de solutions le
japon a développé un programme pour
venir en aide aux régions éloignées
le four ou sato nausée les japonais
peuvent envoyer une partie de leurs
impôts et préfectures de leur choix
contre des produits locaux de l'endroit
comme des oursins du crabe et du sac et
dont le maire de hem beaucoup ça ne sert
à rien nous n'avons rien à offrir en
retour c'est une utile pour nous
lance-t-il
certaines communautés organise même des
séances de rencontres éclair question
d'augmenter le taux de natalité les
histoires à succès démographique en
région éloignée au japon sont plutôt
rares mais à trois heures de tgv à
l'ouest de tokyo
naoshima a trouvé sa recette pour
stabiliser sa courbe démographique le
tourisme
les laisser voisines sont reconnues
mondialement pour leur oeuvre d'art et
leur musée les visiteurs font maintenant
des tours cinq cent mille touristes pas
sur l'île chaque année selon le maire
attirant passage les entrepreneurs qui
ouvre des commerces ici ajoutent ils
pour ce professeur le manque de places
en garderie est un problème aussi
plusieurs régions rurales au canada
comme les îles de la madeleine ont le
même problème
choisir entre sa carrière ou devenir
maman crise à une étudiante de
l'université waseda se pose la question
sa mère s'est posé la même question et
l'a quitté son emploi pour l'élever ce
son modèle elle veut contribuer à la
société comme mère aussi mais elle
espère ne pas quitter son emploi pour y
arriver
with a participé à un séminaire avec des
étudiants de l'université de toronto sur
l'immigration est-ce la solution au
problème démographique du japon est une
solution à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
et le gouvernement le c 17 professeurs
une des solutions proposées par le
gouvernement history au programme pour
être serré trois cent mille étudiants
internationaux d'ici 2020 présentement
ils sont 260 milles le programme de
travailleurs étrangers temporaires est
aussi déficient selon ces deux
professeurs des possibilités d'abus de
la part d'employeurs sont élevés le
gouvernement encourage les japonais à
faire des bébés
ça ne marche pas l'immigration est un
dossier clos on ne va pas là pendant ce
temps les gens vieillissent le problème
du japon en pays est revenue mais le
temps presse pour certains entrepreneurs
une albert pense déjà ces travailleurs
étrangers l'an prochain la main d'oeuvre
est très très rare comme partout au
québec partout au canada et d'ailleurs
c'est pop s'est pas seulement problème
des îles de la madeleine
le gazon n'est pas toujours plus verte
chez le voisin les défis démographique
des régions rurales et éloignées pouces
comme de la mauvaise herbe partout dans
le monde
ne reste plus qu'à trouver le bon remède
ici fait des pionniers radio-canada dans
un schéma au japon